good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you're watching this
right now you are missing a rare prime
time address from joe biden
biden doesn't give a lot of those for
obvious reasons but tonight's topic is
worthy of the occasion america ladies
and gentlemen is under attack and not
from our usual enemies the threat we
face tonight is existential but is not
coming from barefoot religious
extremists living in caves it's not the
chinese government it's not even
vladimir putin himself the most
diabolically evil man in history no
ladies and gentlemen this threat is
worse than all of that and it's
homegrown as they say in the horror
movies it's coming from inside the house
the single gravest threat to america
today
is republican voters all 75 million of
them they are nazis and destroyers of
democracy they must be stopped that is
the message of joe biden's speech just
moments ago he referred to maga forces
or apparently marshalling at red lobster
near you ready to take over this country
now to underscore how deeply joe biden
means all of this tonight's address in
philadelphia is not being categorized as
a campaign event ahead of the midterm
elections which is what it looks like no
instead this speech has the full
sponsorship of the white house
in other words what joe biden is saying
right now is the official position of
the entire executive branch of the us
government that would include the
justice department the various intel
agencies and the world's most powerful
standing military think about that
does it make you nervous
you don't have to be a trump voter to
see a speech like this as a turning
point in american history
for hundreds of years the u.s has had a
political system comprised of two
competing parties
if you were to declare one of those
parties criminal and illegitimate what
would you be left with
will you be left with a one-party state
and that is what joe biden is calling
for tonight a one-party state
it's shocking you may have trouble
believing it's even happening and yet it
is live on television right now
and yet and here's what we're here to
tell you believe it or not there is an
upside to this catastrophe
even as you watch your beloved country
take a turn you never imagined possible
there is reason for hope
american liberals may have obvious
dictatorial ambitions there's no
question they do
only would be dictators fear free speech
and an armed population but just because
liberals long for a one-party state
doesn't mean they're going to get one
they won't in the end they don't have
the skills to pull that off liberals are
too incompetent to overthrow democracy
and that's obvious from history every
successful authoritarian revolution has
had two things in common a coherent
worldview and a competent military force
lenin
for example lenin had the writings of
karl marx to provide an ideological
justification for his revolution and he
had the military genius of leon trotsky
to pull it off together these two things
were enough to topple the czar and take
control of the world's biggest country
for all his power joe biden does not
have these two things marx and trotsky
no joe biden has taylor lorenz and mark
milley
lorenz is the ideological anchor of the
biden white house she's its muse it's
che guevara they are inspired by her
revolutionary fervor but taylor lorenz
does not write weighty books
twitter is her canvas
and having surveyed her urv
we can tell you that lorenz's main idea
appears to be that anyone who doesn't
wear an n95 mask in the shower is a
racist that's the sum total of her
ideology
now there are probably several dozen
people in cambridge who agree with that
but it is hardly the basis of a popular
movement
it's not marxism it's whining so that's
a problem for biden and then there's
mark milley the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff millie is joe biden's
leon trotsky but without the brilliance
or the cool mustache mark milley is a
buffoon he couldn't even manage to
successfully withdraw forces from a
country that wanted them to leave
mark milley's only victories take place
at lunch pizza is afraid of him no one
else is
so these are the people who are trying
to bring us a one-party state
for the next several minutes we'd like
to show you the face of joe biden's
revolution it is heartening the next
time you feel afraid for the future of
this country the next time you think
these people actually want to hurt me
because obviously they do
remember who we're talking about here
and you'll feel better
we're going to start tonight with joe
biden's minister of information a person
called karine jean-pierre
corinne jean-pierre may be the most
self-discrediting spokesman in the
history of revolutionary politics she
makes baghdad bob from the sodom years
look dignified she's literally beyond
belief here she was on monday
somebody unvaccinated comes over
on a plane you say that's not okay
somebody walks into texas or arizona
unvaccinated they're allowed to stay
why but that's not how it works like we
actually no you know that that's not
what you guys want to happen but that is
what has happened but that's not it's
not like somebody walks over and
that's not that's not how exactly what's
happening
thousands of people are walking in a day
some of them
turn themselves over some of them are
caught tens of thousands a week are not
that is what is happening
it's not like someone just walks over
the border carries you up here laughs at
that idea waves her hand
so there are two options to explain
what's going on here either karine
jean-pierre doesn't have a television
set and has no idea what's happening in
america right now that's entirely
possible
or we think this is more likely she has
seen the tape but just doesn't recognize
what it is she cannot discern people
just walking over the border when she
sees pictures of people just walking
over the border that's possible she is
that stupid
want another example
well here she is apparently with total
sincerity assessing a recent speech by
governor ron desantis of florida
and just last week you had governor ron
desantis suggested that dr fauci should
be physically assaulted
and former president trump has done the
same many many times
whoa she looks concerned and frankly so
are we
whatever you think of ron desantis if
he's calling for dr fauci to be
physically assaulted that cannot stand
that is bad that's violence
but of course the question is and it's
always the question with karine
jean-pierre
did that actually happen
thankfully we have the tape here it is
you have people like fauci saying that
his lockdowns didn't cause any permanent
damage to any young kids and i'm just
sick of seeing him i know he says he's
going to retire someone needs to grab
that little elf and chuck him across the
potomac
there it is someone needs to grab that
little elf and chuck him across the
potomac
karine jean-pierre was horrified by this
elf chucking that's not even legal not
since the early days of the howard stern
show has this nation put up with elf
chucking
and by the way who is ron desantis that
he can physically throw a federal
employee all the way across the potomac
river which is very wide in parts and
jean-pierre knows that because she lives
there
was he hercules or something this man is
dangerous
chucking an elf across the potomac
and not only that desantis just outed
tony fauci is an elf elf that's the word
he used not an approved word
that's a threat to national security it
is indeed disinformation probably
russian
everyone knows that tony fauci is very
tall
that's science
and that
ladies and gentlemen is karine jump here
so of all the jobs you could hire karine
jean-pierre for a professional hand
waver would be probably the first if you
need someone to wave a hand and look
confused
she's at the top of your of your list
but if you need someone who can speak
english in a fluent way and communicate
ideas that the rest of us are able to
understand might be
at the very bottom of your list
but they hired her anyway
and the result is amazing and as we said
earlier heartening these are the leaders
of the revolution today for example
karine jean-pierre defined the term
extremist for us you never hear that
ever defined but she defined it today
from the podium an extremist is anyone
whose views differ from we're quoting
the majority of americans so if your
views are different from the majority
you're an extremist
so here's the best part
korean jean-pierre works for a guy who's
got a 38
approval rating so the question before
the class today is 38 percent less or
more than the majority
math is not karine jump here strong suit
and of course it's not her boss's strong
suit either
cognition is not his strong suit this is
the man who took orders from men in
easter bunny costumes
this is the man who chose as his vice
president
someone who feels need to say mankind
and woman kind as if they're completely
separate categories watch this
the artemis program is is the beginning
of the next era
of what we have a history and a
tradition of doing
of providing vision and inspiring
innovation in a way that is going to
benefit all mankind and womankind
okay so not only is it going to benefit
mankind you got to include the ladies
here
womankind will benefit as well trans
kind that goes without say
trans kind always benefits when joe
biden's president
so you have to wonder how different
things might look if they had people
with an iq of over say 85 in positions
of authority in the biden white house
that would be really really scary but
they don't
they don't at all
and
if they had people serving them in the
media who were smarter they could
probably get away with this kind of
thing they could convince people it's
totally normal to use words like
womankind
that would be terrifying if our media if
msnbc were able to convince you that
womankind was a thing
but thank heaven the media as annoying
as they may be
lack self-awareness to the point that we
don't have to worry at all
and to prove it we have a dispatch from
one of joe biden's most fervent
supporter someone who will definitely
have a position in the coming revolution
and that would be max boot max boot of
the washington post professional
warmonger turned liberal professional
warmonger he just wrote a piece about
the how the real america is actually the
most liberal america we're just going to
quote from the peace and let you assess
and keep in mind this is part of the
biden brain trust we're quoting i've
been spending time in some of the most
liberal enclaves in america first
martha's vineyard where former president
barack obama has a house bit of a
bragger max boot and then going back to
the quote provincetown mass an lgbtq
mecca where pride flags are ubiquitous
what did max boot do in provincetown
we're not going to pry we're merely
quoting from the piece and here it is i
even took my step kids to a drag show
so if there is one sentence that kind of
sums up the npr revolution we're living
through and we're going to say it again
i took my step kids to a drag show
unfortunately the step kids were not
interviewed about their perceptions of
the drag show but i took my step kids to
a drag show has got to be the greatest
boast of all time can you say that have
you taken your step kids to a drag show
probably not
but you know what max boot discovered
from taking his step kids to a drag show
and we're quoting provincetown is the
real america so is martha's vineyard
in fact he said we're still growing
because we can't stop ourselves and of
course he can't stop himself and we're
quoting they might be more
representative of 2022 america than the
rust belt diners where reporters love to
take the pulse of
lendia
they're not taking their step kids to
drag shows at the rust belt diners i'll
tell you that
but they will when we're done with them
they're probably not going to get there
max boot is going to be too distracted
there are drag shows every weekend you
can take your step kids to drag shows
all over the country
so he's not going to have time
to affect this revolution it was pretty
therapeutic reading all of this
all you have to do is pay close
attention to them listen to what they
say read what they write
and a calm comes over you
they're so dumb
they probably can't hurt you we can't
stop ourselves she's another example
he's finally calling out republican
semi-fascist behavior where is this
version of joe biden been hiding all
along was his semi-fascism label in your
opinion unfounded
absolutely not the republican party of
today under donald trump is a
semi-fascist party president biden did
the right thing he did the right thing
by challenging them and calling them a
mega
magafestus
semi-fascist
mentality what do you think about the
president calling millions of americans
semi-fascist
listen he's got to express and be honest
about what he feels in his heart and his
soul and now he's out saying
two things one lots of you all are
fascists
and by the way if if you vote republican
there's a decent chance that our
democracy is no longer going to exist i
got to tell you scott a lot of folks
would go where's the lie i don't see no
lies detected
saying semi-fascists leads me only to
the question
what semi about that
it's full-on fascism
that's the brain dress ladies and
gentlemen why only semi-fascist why not
full fascist and what's what's the
difference joe scarborough talk to us
more about criminal behavior i find it
really reassuring
um but the point of course is that
journalism
is when you repeat what the people in
power say verbatim and then you
congratulate them for their insight
so how does the rest of the world see
this now we play these clips all the
time and you know they're annoying
but if you were taking a cold calculated
look at the people in charge of the
united states if you were a foreign
adversary and you're thinking what are
we up against
what would you make of this imagine
being
in the taliban two years ago you're a
taliban commander and you happen to flip
on msnbc
and you think to yourself this is
america's news media
really
i mean my native language is urdu and
even i can tell these people are
freaking stupid
but their secretary of state must be
impressive right he's the secretary of
state let's check on youtube and here's
what you find
[Music]
jump and shout
out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
imagine being the taliban with their
turbans and their aks and tony
blinkenstarts wagging his finger at them
oh you must release the hostages or else
or else what pal well turns out nothing
taliban gets to keep our tanks and our
helicopters and tony blinken goes back
to performing hoochie coochie man did he
take his
kids to the drag show this weekend
probably they all did
we should tell you that all these people
on msnbc and at the state department
officially or not work for joe biden so
the dumbness may flow downhill like
certain
other fluid matters
joe biden
doesn't even appear to realize that his
military his pentagon which he oversees
lost the withdrawal from afghanistan in
fact it was just this week that joe
biden claimed very loudly that americans
would need personal f-15s if they wanted
to overpower the us government
there's no way you could beat us
you're not sophisticated enough
you're not illiterate
militia in the poorest country in the
world
there's no way
and he made that argument with such
confidence you have to wonder if anyone
told him what happened in kabul let's
look back oh last year
he also doesn't appear to realize that
he's accusing unarmed january 6
protesters of nearly toppling american
democracy for good
really
if you're afraid of ashley babbitt so
afraid you have to shoot her in the neck
and murder her
you probably don't feel very secure
so these are not people who believe
they're strong is the truth and watching
this it's kind of fascinating actually
and on some level it's reassuring
because again they're weak and afraid
our plus-sized defense secretary
promises to crack down on joe biden's
political opponents oh extremism white
supremacy then he flies around the world
in a space suit and then he gets coveted
anyway
now to show you how strong he is and to
strike terror in the hearts of our
adversaries he's issuing powerful new
regulations requiring senior leaders in
the military to stop using gendered
pronouns well that'll show him we've got
diversity back off
so you can no longer use the terms he or
she or male or female according to the
washington free beacon which got the
military's order the u.s pacific air
forces responsible for containing china
believe that eliminating gender pronouns
will improve the military's quote
lethality
[Laughter]
diversity is lethality
now of course on one level it's
terrifying because no this is a sign of
buffoonery and weakness and the rest of
the world is laughing at us and making
calculations accordingly but probably
good news for you as the subject of joe
biden's coming crackdown because when
they come to arrest you for your thought
crimes
they're going to have no idea what you
look like the warrant won't say
it'll identify you as they them or maybe
jesus
you can imagine the confusion at that
point it's easy to get out of it you
simply identify with a straight face as
pansexual to spirit and indigenous and
at that point they will slink away in
shame you're safe
diversity was your shield
but the best news of all for all of us
in this country is that lori lightfoot
inevitably will occupy some elevated
position in joe biden's coming
revolution how do we know because she's
the single worst mayor in the country
she's stupid she's mean she's openly
racist so of course she is due for a big
promotion in the biden regime
now you might remember that when the
previous administration started
enforcing federal immigration law lori
lightfoot cut off ice's access to city
databases quote
chicago will always be a welcoming city
and a champion for the rights of our
immigrant and refugee communities
communities that didn't actually live
here at the time they live in other
countries because they're foreign
nationals they're not americans
but lori lightfoot took a position
anyway and she took it in the most
affirmative possible way
to behave differently she insisted at
the time and we're quoting would be
cruel
and you know what the word is you know
what's coming don't you racist
well this week the governor of texas
decided to test lori lightfoot's
commitment to anti-racism he began
transporting illegal aliens from the
border in texas all the way to chicago
and why wouldn't he do that lori
lightfoot has said emphatically she
wants them in her city she's not a
racist you're the racist
so these migrants showed up how did
gloria lightfoot respond
well
lori lightfoot's administration declared
that this plan is do you know the answer
can you guess
pick up the pen write it down no
cheating
racist
so it's racist not to want illegal
aliens in your city and it's racist when
people send them
so take three steps back what's
happening here this is really
a recruitment experience no one in the
history of politics has created
single-handedly more right-wingers than
lori lightfoot
imagine her in your new position in the
bide administration screaming on npr
every morning biden state broadcaster to
tell you whether she's decided whether
you can use your electric car today or
not can we drive our electric car today
i don't know let's tune in to minister
lightfoot she'll tell us
everyone knows that's coming and if
there's anything that will provoke a
counter-revolution it's that so we're
gonna be fine
lori lightfoot may have genocidal
impulses she definitely does but like
the rest of our leaders she is too
stupid to pull them off subscribe to the
fox news youtube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
tucker carlson tonight